would you consider doing a Gilmore Girls
musical just asking for a friend
[Applause]
so I guess it was a running joke on the
show morning show where they assign one
of the reporters to cover Gilmore Girls
the musical and the person is like
rolling their eyes because you know it
seems silly but but then there's
discussion that no it's a beloved show I
mean I always felt that that language
and that kind of pace and the way the
tone of the show is very easy actresses
very broad way it is consonant you have
to take a deep long breath before you
deliver some of those lines they come on
yeah ever so I think it's kind of a good
idea I think I think I mean she loves
dance and there's so much dance always
in the show so but again as I told you
if you ask me to sing I'll just show up
so really we can you know actually put
it on Broadway or in your garage
you're like I'm not I can be fancy and
looky that's right I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this